année scolaire 1965 pour la première
fois les écoliers français ne sont pas
tous en vacances en même temps le pays
est alors divisé en deux zones pour les
vacances d'hiver de printemps mais aussi
celles d'été six ans plus tard en 1971
les zones de vacances passent ensuite
pour la première fois de deux à trois
zones à b et c un découpage qui vaudra
jusqu'au début des années 80 premiers
effets prévisibles de ces mesures
désengorger les autoroutes au début
juillet et sans doute réduire
l'hécatombe sur les routes le tourisme
devrait aussi profiter de l'étalement
des vacances
l'économie touristique profitera
effectivement de cet étalement des
vacances voulue par les gouvernements
successifs en décalant d'une semaine ou
deux les départs en vacances des
écoliers des différentes régions
l'arrivée sur les zones touristiques est
aussi étalé résultat au lieu de deux
semaines les professionnels travaillent
activement pendant un mois un argument
économique au profit du rythme des
enfants selon cette association de
parents d'élèves
mais nous pensons que ces mesures
répondent le plus aux exigences du
tourisme
et de départs en vacances dès la sncf de
tous ces problèmes plutôt que des
impératifs pédagogiques et nous sommes
que ce nous sommes que les mesures
fragmentaire qui ne résoudront pas le
problème des rythmes scolaires au cours
des ans le découpage des vacances
scolaires changera encore plusieurs fois
en 1981 par exemple le gouvernement
optait pour un étalement des vacances à
la carte
laissés au choix des 30 recteurs
d'académie une idée qui n'arrangeait pas
vraiment certains professionnels du
tourisme bien le mauvais étalement des
vacances se traduit pour nous par une
demande accrue de passagers sur des
jours de points que nous ne pourrons pas
y traiter c'est bien évident sous la
pression des professionnels du tourisme
le gouvernement reviendra à trois zones
de vacances à partir de 1991
encore une fois des parents d'élèves
dénonçait la pression de l'économie
touristique et particulièrement celle de
l'or bleu basé l'essentiel des du
calendrier scolaire sur des activités
qui ne sont pas pratiques et de fait par
la grande majorité de nos élèves
c'est ne pas prendre en compte leur ont
pas leur offrir les meilleures
conditions pour réussir aujourd'hui les
zones de vacances sont toujours au
nombre de trois seule la répartition des
académies a changé depuis 2015 avec le
nouveau découpage des régions
[Musique]